welcome to this video playing sniper two
thousand six years at charlize story
could be right than author on the sniper
plays like that at least and it's this
is one of the books that I really don't
like to be perfectly honest yeah he had
this in the book okay let's think
briefly Queen d2 night of six okay if it
takes you change okay takes you three
and so let's see that I get rid of the
double porn quickly go from there the
only thing I don't like is my
development is not so great
okay could have played t5 I should have
prevented that but you didn't play it
so is that a good position for black
I've got two bishops against two nights
and we both have a somewhat questionable
pawn structure some tix yeah it might
take that but i can go queen bee three
all song here yeah king of seven is a
pretty decent way to cover things and
i'm not sure i could also take that's
not entirely stupid and let's do it
okay check so he very happily traded in
to a bad end game just a question how
bad it is is it okay maybe it's might
get the King 37 and then it's I can do
this yeah it is bad that is it is pretty
bad he looked d 6 or F was also
interesting let's start with rooty six
so I can go here now 97's rookie 6 it's
just the dominating bishop and it was
pretty clear I mean he went for that
very in a very straightforward way but
it was really just a question if this is
a bad end game or or losing or it's just
a matter of how bad it is it turned out
to be it is very very bad
check so this should be 6 mm yeah I'll
show of them's maybe an alternative but
that's pretty good bring the King up
I shall play king d for first probably
it shouldn't change the result but it
was not not a good technical plane
check
Knight to c3 is the is the idea mmm now
I cannot cover the porn easily
I think I should just remote
check the e pawn is too quick
yeah no waste is no way to stop that
black resigns yeah just wittingly traded
into a lost end game quite quite
surprisingly okay so this is an uncommon
line the thing that that's really this
is not something that I'd like to that I
like to play but I was I wanted to do
this first but I couldn't quite I can go
every year I forgot about that idea I
was seeing this and this irritated me a
little bit this is probably just good
down now that is good okay then this is
preferable not allowing that this pawn
doubling in the first place I made one
mistake here quite clearly hear hear no
I have to play see 494 this is a mistake
you can go d5 now I think ok I've now
I've got 95 ok that's it's not so
straightforward it's not so
straightforward ok I went here 94-95
yeah also again i'm unsure how you can
spend three as three seconds on a move
like that where you really change the
pawn structure considerably here ticks
ticks ticks yeah now back in crete
quincy three it's just just a bad idea
c3 is the only weakness that i have and
he trades that and after Queen this is
just bad e six is hanging king of 727 is
no good and yes this MK mr. disaster
just a disaster the engine is r plus 1
we cannot keep the C file
and here this is just a terrible
pressure if he does that I have a half
for threatening f5 I mean this is pretty
obvious that this Bishop is far better
than that night yeah this is what's
helped this happened in the game when I
take him a check ya know this is the
opening winning endgame I made a mistake
though on one mistake here here I should
play this first that that's easier and
then G 3f wats bit simpler but i think
that wins as well the porn is just ashes
too quick yeah that's also win yeah he
went into this end game and a pretty
relaxed fashion it was just just losing
very nice Ronnie I've got nine wins in a
row with Noah no loss bit lucky in one
or two games but in general good run
approaching the 2500 mark very nice
thanks for watching